but i love rapping i love freestyle rap
that is rap that is made up that's not
written well yeah we're going to we're
going to um the thing with freestyle is
it requires your input you know it's not
prepared so you guys are going to tell
me what you want to rap about if you are
in this segment here let's get a
suggestion and then we'll we'll have
some fun so what would you like
yeah if you you've got a hand up here
very casually yeah
a briss
is that just because i spoke about
foreskins and you were like uh does he
know does he know that briss is the
jewish name for the circumcision
ceremony i do yeah um okay a bris
it's a good word in it it's onomatopoeic
um let's come to if you're in this kind
of rectangle here what would you like a
wrap
oh fidel castro i thought you said fetal
castro
i was like
that's amazing yeah
fidel castro great fidel castro
what
oh did you just say go no we have to get
three more suggestions first we can't
just do a rap and we could do a rap
about bris and fidel castro but these
people will be upset because they've
been doing their thinking
um let's
they're kind of like the kind of shadowy
table over here one second you're not in
that segment
and also this the suez canal would have
been a great suggestion a year ago when
people were like oh remember the boat
that was stuck in it
um people on this table like what do you
want to rap about
okay well well done for teaming up
were you all in the girl scouts
yeah who was
maybe
when you got your i've you are too drunk
to
to engage um
maybe i was in the girl scouts it could
have just been some people that invited
me to their house and
made me give them cookies i don't know
girl scouts fidel castro bris um
who down here is putting their hand up
so eagerly yeah there's a table here of
people you're just so polite i love that
when like a british person's like i'm
gonna do a rap you're like well we'll
behave ourselves and we'll take we'll
put our hands up
a persian rug cool yeah
why are you upset with that
excited oh you're persian no but do you
uh
they're [ __ ] expensive rugs isn't it
because i was my wife was like we need
to get a rug for this room and i was
like oh let's get a persian rug and we
looked up and like genuine persian rugs
are like in the thousands so we we got
an afghan rug which is like similar and
good
and it arrived
and then a week later
afghanistan fell
and so like every time i'm in our front
room i like just like
just look down at it and i'm just like
we got you out little buddy don't worry
we
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're safe now don't worry
don't worry
okay
persian rugs bris fidel castro girl
scouts um and then we'll come to kind of
like the kind of area here what you guys
want to wrap up
so you said chlamydia and you said
lindisfarne lindisfarne is inherently
more interesting than chlamydia
lindisfarne is is a monastery that you
can be accessed at low tide you can walk
across to it correct yeah cool yeah
okay yeah you all want chlamydia but no
[ __ ] off
[Applause]
linda's fun
are you enjoying that i say [ __ ] off yes
okay
so fidel castro girl scouts lindisfarne
persian rug and bris those are some
lovely suggestions guys and this is
going to be a lovely freestyle rap if we
can drop that beat good sir it's all
made up it's all improvised and it's
based on your suggestions and um
yeah oh [ __ ] this is this is a this
is a fly beat i'm excited it's pretty
chill it's pretty chill because it's
like a monday in it mate it's monday
nice cool
chill upon a monday you enjoy this see
you a jewish man if you are you probably
got the bris i don't know not taking
down your pants so i could check you'll
be looking at the lady to your side like
what's next is he gonna examine there
like delving grabbing on the balls get
the whole thing the foreskin is gone
removed in the past aye aye they like to
magnify a kind of creepy rabbi looking
down their ceremonial on the scissor he
likes to chop it off with precision are
you a jewish man going through the
surgery you're looking confused with the
uncertainty like the lady over there
when i was asking about if in your
childhood you were in the girl scouts
you were so confused like slightly drunk
saying silver rewards i thunk i think is
what you got you were there in the troop
selling so many cookies feeling
cock-a-hoop boy scouts coming in time to
call a truce did you ever go camping can
you deduce how to set up a tent or do
some knots i like the boy scouts more
but the girl's more hot not of that age
i'm not saying that i'm going wild even
though in the accident if i say
pedophile is fine let me talk about the
opposite end of a spectrum down in cuba
with my friend noshay guevara the guy
that led the whole shebang fidel castro
motor [ __ ] man with a good beard yeah
the best by far his son raul is alive
but fidel's like cigars because he's
burnt up and gone believed in the
country if he's alive still anyway stunk
these facts he was down there please be
aware when it comes to having good
health care fidel established it so much
on offer per person in cuba they got
more doctors than any other place the
reading and the education is real good
that's the situation a communist
rebellion getting free of dictators but
then turned into one himself later still
it don't matter i don't mind if i had
chlamydia still i had a fun time going
off to the doctor i had my fill yeah it
drips drip strips but i get the pill and
they arrive why cause online they're
prescribed discreet in the package it's
right by my side i shouldn't have the
sex still we can all agree in your life
you're gonna get two or three stds and
it doesn't even matter if i go home then
i couldn't be madder than if i spilt red
wine they're on my rock i don't rock the
persian i'm not a rich thug i've gotta
get the afghan if still i had plenty of
money get persians from back in the 70s
if you don't persian geographic
understand it's basically said if you
are from iran but don't like the modern
day people there you'll be down there
not in head with your hair saying yo
chris he knows it ever so amazing uh
what was the other topic that we're
raising remind me about it now this'll
do the charm i think about the monks way
back in linda's farm they were non-too
shabby hanging out on the abbey they saw
the little nuns they were like she's a
baddie but we can't do anything yeah set
them straight they're abbott and linda's
farms like you celebrate and so they've
got to sit there but no masturbate the
monks on linda's fan yeah they really
hey you can go and visit it no need to
take a ship if the tide's going low you
can just walk to it looking like there
oh and now we've arrived but then you're
stuck for another day at the high tide
so you're twiddling your thumbs learning
about the history of all the monks at
the monastery to me a mystery so maybe
just look it up online not in your house
while you're sat on persian rugs
wondering about the girl scout
you